il porte bien son nom ce petit commerce
de quartier les voisines font de bonnes
affaires malgré la pandémie on se trouve
chanceuse dans ta trident heureusement
les clients vraiment à coeur de sites
miroirs commerces de quartier
un optimisme partagé un peu plus loin
sur la plaza st-hubert où les temps déjà
été très dur surtout avec tous les
commerçants qui malheureusement ferme
autour de nous j'ai vraiment
l'impression que c'est ça en fait qui
vient comme réveiller un peu dans la
conscience collective
on y croise même par hasard la mairesse
de montréal dans son quartier c'est pas
les géants du commerce en ligne car
besoin nous là c'est pas eux
c'est nos commerçants nos entreprises la
cac qui ont besoin nous pour leur survie
acheter québécois acheter montréalais
jamais avons-nous autant parlé de
l'importance d'encourager les petits
commerces d'ici surtout pour les achats
du temps des fêtes
on essaie de faire le plus possible
locale c'est à nu ça va dans des petites
boutiques parce que vu l'achalandage la
j'évite les gros sandwich pour ça que je
suis sur la rue fleury
mais tout n'est pas gagné selon un
sondage de la fédération canadienne des
entreprises indépendantes
le deux tiers du budget du temps des
fêtes des canadiens iraient aux grandes
entreprises américaines et aux géants du
web
c'est quand même assez à ce inquiétant
quand on sait que 62% des petits
détaillants n'ont pas encore retrouvé
leurs ventes normales
d'où l'importance maintenant de faire
mentir ces chiffres la ccgq mais c'est
tout ça me sert vient d'europe
mais si le prix qui demeure la plus
grande barrière selon cet expert
or si d'acheter local j'ai un petit
marché
ça leur coûte 25 % plus que s'ils vont
chercher vous donne dans une grande
surface mais moi je suis pas du tout
certain que ces gens là pour
l'encourager
surtout que l'année a été difficile pour
plusieurs sur le plan financier
issigeac audry charbonneau radio canada
mon frère